bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir vous la reconnaissez c'est une
grande dame du journalisme politique
bonsoir Nathalie saintc et merci d'être
notre grand témoin ce soir on vous
connaît bien sûr comme éditorialiste à
France Télévision mais c'est comme
romancière qu'on a le plaisir de vous
recevoir ce soir l'ombre d'un traître
c'est votre 2e roman aux éditions de
l'Observatoire c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune apprenti journaliste hein dans les
années 60 qui va retrouver au centre
d'une affaire qui le dépasse c'est aussi
une manière de nous interroger votre
roman sur ce qu'est la résistance et ce
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui on en
parlera dans la deuxème partie notre
grand débat ce soir l'Union nationale
contre l'antisémitisme est-elle
impossible il elbron Pivet Gérard
Larcher appelle à une grande marche ce
dimanche une marche qui devrait
rassembler largement mais qui déjà
divise les insoumis ne s'y rendront pas
et la présence de Marine Le Pen et du RN
fait débat alors pourquoi cette cause ne
fait plus l'unanimité dans notre pays on
en débat dans un instant sur ce plateau
avant de retrouver nos affranchis pour
leur parti prix ce soir le billet
européen de Richard verli le monde dans
tous ses états d'Isabelle Lasserre et
puis Bourbon Express bien sûr signé el
min Gava voilà pour le menu on y va
Nathalie SARC ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti
le 3e et le 4e personnage de l'État
ensemble pour défendre la République
Gérard Larcher et yel Bron pievet
appelle donc les Français à marcher
contre l'antisémitisme ce dimanche dans
tout le pays le cortège s'élancera à
Paris de l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat
mais déjà cette manifestation suscite
malaise et division comme si cette cause
ne pouvait plus rassembler toutes les
forces politiques dans notre pays alors
pourquoi et à qui la faute bonsoir
Antoine Armand bonsoir et bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes député renaissance
de Haute Savoie vous défilerez ce
dimanche dans votre circonscription
d'Ancy bonsoir Rodrigo Arenas bonsoir
bienvenue député la France insoumise de
Paris vous vous aviez défilé en toute
discrétion vous nous en aviez parlé ici
même autre cadero au lendemain de
l'attaque terroriste du ramas en Israël
du 7 octobre c'était une manifestation à
l'appel du CRIF nous c'est pas très
discret mais vous pouvez le dire vous
nous direz si vous irez contrairement à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et au collègue soumis
ce dimanche ou pas bonsoir Kevin
mauvieux bonsoir vous aussi vous
défilerez ce dimanche député
rassemblement national de l'heure et
porte-parole du rassemblement national
et puis bonsoir Galina Elbaze bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes la vice-présidente
de la Licra la Ligue internationale
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
inutile de vous dire Nathalie SAR qu'on
a besoin de vous dans ce débat on a
besoin de votre décryptage des stratégie
des uns et des autres qu'elles sont
parfois difficiles à suivre je vous
donne la parole dans un instant on
plante le décor comme chaque soir pour
commencer ce débat avec Stéphane
Blakowski dans son chrono tout de
suite et je me retourne pour vous
accueillir comme chaque soir mon cher
Stéphane bonsoir à vous bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à toutes et toutes alors cette
marche et ben vous l'avez dit hein
c'était un appel lancé par Yael Bron
Pivet et Gérard Larcher pour marcher
dimanche à Paris contre l'antisémitisme
avec une phrase dans cette tribune
mettant en cause la montée de
l'islamisme en France ces derniers temps
alors il y a at-il un lien toujours
est-il que le premier à réagir à cet
appel à marcher contre l'antisémitisme
c'était Jordan Bardella qui parlait bien
sûr au nom de son parti il n'était pas
le seul évidemment quelques minutes plus
tard d'autres eux aussi ont rallé cet
appel en l'occurrence Stepan séjourné le
patron du du parti Renaissance voyez qui
va marcher dimanche sauf que 1 heure
plus tard ah il republié un tweet mais
cette fois un peu plus long le tweet
parce qu'il explique que il ne voudrait
pas défiler avec le FN pour ne pas
banaliser un un parti qui a été fondé
par des antisémites effectivement il y a
un embarras à noter que communistes et
socialistes sont dans le même embarras
on veut bien marcher oui mais en tout
cas pas à côté de Marine Le Pen alors
pour sa défense de son côté le
rassemblement national rappelle que en
2015 lorsque Jean-Marie Le Pen avait de
nouveau c'était de nouveau livré des
provocations antisémites et bien 4 mois
plus tard le résultat c'est qu'il avait
été viré du FN justement à cause de ces
propos antisémites mais là où il y a un
problème c'est que en fait on on a viré
Jean-Marie Le Pen du FN parce qu'il
disait les choses antisémites sauf que
Jordane Bardella nous dit queah
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas antisémite
on écoute l'excellent Benjamin dul
Jean-Marie Le Pen pour vous n'était pas
antisémite ou n'est pas antisémite non
mais je ne suis pas juge monsieur du les
juges ont parlé puisquil a été condamné
mais les juges ont parl je ne crois pas
que Jean-Marie Le Pen était antisémite
alors forcément face à un tel dénis
Olivier Verant ne s'est pas fait prier
hier pour souligner les ambigués du
rassemblement national on l'écoute cê au
question au gouvernement vous êtes le
parti de la flamme il n'y a pas un bon
et anti un bon et un mauvais
antisémitisme il n'y a qu'un
antisémitisme et quand le président de
votre parti politique il y a 2 jours
refuse de reconnaître que le président
fondateur de votre parti le Front
national a été condamné par la justice
française pour antisémitisme vous ne
servez pas la côte que vous prétendez
servir bref à la sortie du Conseil des
ministres Verant a dit aujourd'hui que
is Élisabeth B participerait à cette
marche dimanche mais bien sûr le plus
loin possible du des membres du
rassemblé nationale qui selon le
gouvernement n'a pas sa place dans la
manif du côté des insoumis en revanche
avant d'éventuellement participer à une
marche contre l'antisémitisme on pose
ces conditions on écoute manuel Bompard
si Madame par exemple madame Bron pivé
et Monsieur Larcher disent que les
choses soient claires il ne peut pas y
avoir dans les rang de cette
manifestation des des membres du
rassemblement national alors la question
pourrait se poser vous avez entendu la
question pourrait se poser c'estàd que
même si le RN était banni de cette
manifestation c'est pas pour autant que
Manuel bonpard irait à la manifestation
il se poserait la question
éventuellement d'y aller cela dit que
chez les insoumis vous savez que quand
on se pose des questions c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui apporte la réponse donc il
a publié un tweet hier pour dire donc
pas question de participer à cette manif
qui dit-il sous prétexte de
d'antisémitisme apporte son soutien
inconditionnel au massacre alors faut
savoir que dans le vocabulaire de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce qu'il appelle le
massacre c'est la repost israélienne au
terroristes du Hamas donc les insoumis
nous expliquent qu'ils ne veulent pas
aller manifester à cause de la présence
du est-ce que c'est crédible pas tout à
fait je vous rappelle qu'en 2019 Marine
Le Pen avait dit oui j'appelle à
manifester contre la réforme des
retraites et Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
très content qu'elle rejoigne les
cortèges en soulignant ses progrès dans
le domaine de l'humanisme bon
apparemment il a changé d' vie voilà ça
peut arriver en politique mais sur un
sujet comme celui-ci c'est peut-être
plus grave et plus important bref
saons-nous faire la preuve d'un minimum
d'unité nationale dimanche le débat est
ouvert en tout cas c'est mal parti
manifestement merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane Antoine les actes antisémites
ont littéralement explosé on est à plus
de 1000 depuis seulement un mois c'est
plus du double que l'année dernière
toute entière et cette fois ce qui
change c'est plus les les associations
le CRIF la communauté juive qui appelle
à défiler contre l'antisémitisme ce sont
les premiers représentants de la nation
qu'est-ce que ça change et pourquoi
cette marche est à vos yeux importante
vous l'avez dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur l'a rappelé aujourd'hui on a
presque trois fois plus d'actes
antisémite en un mois
que pendant toute l'année dernière et il
y a donc aujourd'hui dans notre pays une
résurgence de l'antisémitisme dans ses
formes les plus affreuses et les plus
abominables et l'antisémitisme c'est un
poison pour la République pourquoi vous
connaissez tous cette formule de Sartre
c'est l'antisémite qui désigne le Juif
c'est une forme de racisme c'est une
forme de discrimination mais c'est aussi
une forme de complottisme de
stigmatisation qui vise à miner la
confiance que nous avons dans la société
et qui a menené aux pires horreurs mais
comment garantir qu'elle soit puissante
cette manifestation quand on voit déjà
les malaises qu'elle sucite cette
manifestation elle est puissante par
construction c'est un fait quasiment
inédit dans l'histoire de notre
République que les deux présidents des
assemblées parlementaires de notre pays
appelleent conjointement à un
rassemblement collectif républicain
citoyen elle est déjà par construction
et ensuite elle le sera puissante par
mobilisation si tout et tous nous nous
mobilisons quand j'ai lancé avec mes
collègues parlementaires avec le
président de mon conseil départemental
avec le maire de mon département avec
les maires de mon département un appel à
une manifestation en haut de sa voix si
au même moment c'est pour donner cette
union et répondre à cet appel qui doit
être un écho qui doit être pour nous
tous et toutes un écho à se réveiller
partout sur le faudrait que le Président
de la République lui-même élu de tous
les Français puissent être présent aussi
pour l'instant il il ne souhaite pas
enfin en tout cas à priori il ne viendra
pas ch c'est son choix il a eu tout à
l'heure des mot extrêmement forts sur le
fait que la République ne transigera pas
donc je pense que ce qui compte c'est
que nous nous regardions tous dans la
même direction parce qu'au fond je le
dis quand même simplement c'est ce
qu'attendent tous nos compatriotes vous
imaginez une seconde je sens je sens
qu'on va l'avoir le débat parce que vous
dites que cette
manifà face à la gravité de ce que nous
vivons à quel point ce n'est pas le
débat ni pour nos compatriotes encore
plus pour nos compatriotes d'origine
juive ou juif qui regardent ce débat
atterré et qui se disent attendez nous
avons trois fois plus d'actes antisémite
en France en un mois que pendant toute
une année débat et prendre de la hauteur
c'est tout à votre honneur mais celui
qui porte la parole de l'exécutif
Olivier verrand porte-parole du
gouvernement c'est lui qui dit
aujourd'hui le RN n'a pas sa place dans
cette marche est-ce que vous êtes
d'accordout le rassemblement national
héritier du Front national n'a jamais eu
et n'aura jamais aucune crédibilité en
matière de lutte contre l'antisémitisme
alors il se trouve qu'ils ont été
rejoints par LFI qui a perdu toute
crédibilité pour parler d'antisémitisme
puisque son père spirituel se délecte de
tweet
TW antisémit qu'est-ce que vous attendez
qu'il ne défile pas ils n'ont pas le
droit d'y aller ou qu'ils soit discret
qu'est-ce que vous attendez nous c'est
un rassemblement pour la tolérance
contre l'antisémitisme nous ne serons
pas là à regarder quel ou quel élu
participe nous manifesterons en
regardant devant et devant c'est la
lutte contre l'ancétisémitisme donc pour
bien comprendre le RN n'a pas sa place
oui ou non vous êtes d'accord avec
Olivier verrand oui ou non bien sûr que
le RN n'a aucune crédibilité en matière
d'antis de lutte contre l'antisémitisme
mais franchement donc il n'a pas sa
place pour le le député Ren tout à
l'heure l'a dit très bienè cl Kevin
mauvieux euh est-ce que vous pouvez
comprendre au regard ne serait-ce que de
l'histoire de votre parti et du fait que
Jean-Marie Le Pen son chef historique a
été plusieurs fois condamné pour
incitation à la haine pour antisémitisme
est-ce que vous pouvez ne serait-ce que
comprendre que la présence du
rassemblement national compte tenu de
cette histoire suscite un malaise non
est-ce qu'on pose la question au Parti
socialiste de sa crédibilité à venir
quand François mitéran a été décoré par
Pétin et le régime de Vichy non donc à
partir du moment où on essaie de faire
des procès à à géométrie variable sur
l'histoire des partis ça ne marche plus
il faut regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national c'est Marine Le
Pen qui en 2015 vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure a exclu Jean-Marie Le
Jean-Marie Le Pen justement parce qu'il
avait des propos qui avaient été
condamnés par la justice et que ça
pouvait laisser placer une laisser
planer une ambiguïé au rassemblement
national nous n'avons aucune ambiguïé
nous sommes contre l'antisémitisme nous
avons toujours lutté contre
l'antisémitisme et nous sommes
d'ailleurs les seuls depuis longtemps à
mettre un mot sur les personnes qui
aujourd'hui en France font monter
l'antisémitisme vous l'avez aussi
rappelé tout à l'heure je ne vous ai pas
coup c'est l'islamisme radical qui
aujourd'hui s'en prend à la communauté
juive estce que vous reconnaissez une
faute de la part de Jordan barnella
alors tout simplement de de nier le réel
puisque les juges ont parlé pour
reprendre le journaliste de BFM TV la
condamnation pour antisitimeme elle
existe alors pourquoi ne peut ne peut-il
pas le reconnaître il y a deux choses le
le le le passage de Jordan Bardella bon
il est un peu tronqué on fait pas voir
toute la tout ce qui a été dit Jordan
Bardella ce qu'il a dit c'est que à
titre personnel il ne pensait pas que
Jean-Marie Le Pen était antisémite mais
il a aussi condamné les propos de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui ont fait l'objet
de condamnation là-dessus il est ferme
et encore une fois Jean-Marie Le Pen on
l'a mis dehors en 2015 à cause de ces
propos donc il y a aucune ambigué il y
plus antisémite au RN il y a plus un
seul antisémite au RN parce que vous
savez on ressort souvent Frédéric
Châtillon les anciens gudard ce groupe
d'extrême monrez-moi le lien aujourd'hui
avec fré ch il ne travaille plus pour
vous il ne travaille plus pour nous et
je vais vous dire pour aller plus loin
et pour reprendre un peu les mots de mon
collègue de renaissance euh qui sur un
point avait raison mais c'est dommage
c'est que ce point n'est pas respecté
jusqu'au bout les Français aujourd'hui
et surtout la communauté juive attendent
autre chose du débat que de ressortir
les vieux démons de réfléchir à quel
parti a des origines qui viendrai de la
francisque quel parti aurait participer
à un pacte germano-soviétique quel parti
aurait étéé nous avons changé mais mais
il faut arrêter avec ce débat là
aujourd'hui il y a des Français juifs
qui ont des étoiles de David qui sont
mises sur leur les les fontons de leur
bâtiments il y a des Français juifs qui
n'osent pas aller faire leur course qui
se sentent mal dans dans la rue et nous
on vient faire des heures de débat à
demander si un député de la nation qui a
été élu démocratiquement à le le débat
làdessus c'est important d'en parler
Rodrigo Arenas Marine Le Pen a rompu
avec le passé antisémite du parti de son
père et de son père qu'est-ce que vous
répondez écoutez moi je suis faire une
histoire j'ai pas d'ambigué je je suis
pas dans un débat de faocus et de
cynique je n'ai rien à faire à côté des
gens d'extrême droite vous savez moi
c'est mon histoire je suis exilé
politique dans ce pays c'est l'extrême
droite qui a pris le pouvoir au Chili
par la pire des façons donc je ne défile
pas à côté de ceux qui ont torturé ma
famille qui ont fait disparaître des
gens parce que c'est leur histoire
commune après moi je peux entendre ce
qu' dit mon collègue à droite là mais
mais voilà on a au moins on a la clarté
de la position on a la clarté de la
position vous m'accorderez ça ah ben
donc maintenant en revanche moi je
laisset
de à sa place dans ce cortège vous
préférez partir c'est ça qu'on comprend
pas bien dans la position des insouis on
parlera de celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
après mais vous vous dites parce que le
RN est là vous n'y allez pas est-ce que
c'est pas une fausse excuse est-ce que
vous pensez
bienvenu ça fa ça fait plusieurs ça fait
plusieurs semaines que le conflit
israélo pardon israëlo-palestinien a
repris même s'il ne s'est jamais arrêté
pendant depuis 70 ans et à chaque
rassemblement auquel j'ai participé j'en
ai fait un certain nombre il a toujours
été rappelé à la fois la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme la lutte contre
l'islamophobie et le cesser le feu je
pense qu'il n'y a pas d'ambiguité de la
position de la France insoumise en tout
cas de la mienne sur ce sujet- là
maintenant on va pas se retrouver ce
dimanche-l précisément parce que nous ne
voulons pas défiler à côté de Marine Le
Pen Jordan bardellaa le Front national
Éric Zemour Marion maréchal Le Pen tout
cette cette espace politique qui
manifestement d'après yel Bron Pivet
représente l'arc républicain je ne me
sens pas appartenir à cet arc
républicain par contre je me sens
appartenir à l'arc démocratique de notre
pays qui me fait participer à ces
rassemblements y compris quand ils sont
pas appelés par la mais pour bien
comprendre si demain il y avait un
attentat type attaclan ouais il y avait
on s'en souvient Angela Merkel qui é
venu si si demain Marine Le Pen veut
défiler en
soutien au pays aux familles des
victimes vous n'irez pas c'est c'est ça
c'est parce qu'ils y vont vous NZ pas
excellent exemple que vous prenez là
vous pouvez aussi prendre la
manifestation qui a eu au lendemain des
attentats Charlie Hebdo et cetera ce
sont notamment le monde la société
civile qui a appelé à cette
manifestation dans lequel les politiques
se sont rallié aujourd'hui moi je pense
que c'est à la société civile de prendre
la là-dessus et de et de nous être
modeste là-dessus parce que je vais vous
dire ce dont on est en train de parler
moi j'ai honte he j'ai honte que les
partis politiques donnent cette image là
aujourd'hui il y a quelque chose qui
doit nous rassembler pour nos enfants de
donner des signes forts moi j'ai quatre
gamins donc la question est là donc
monsieur je vais être très simple avec
vous n nous nous nous ne répondrons pas
à l'appel qui est lancé par yel brun
Pivet et Gérard lâcher sur les bases que
je viens de donner d'ailleurs vous-même
vous avez dit que nous n'avions pas
notre place LFI et RN et d'ailleurs même
le porte-parole de Renaissance a dit que
la LFI n'avaient pas sa place à C
manifestation donc le
un peu curieux dans lequ direient pas
par qu'on pastil alors que précisément
voulez pas qu'on
participeousb très simplement monsieur
aras vous étiez d'ailleurs vous étiez
seul je tiens vous rendre hommage à la
manifestation au lendemain au lendemain
au lendemain des attaques terroristes du
ramas il y avait des élus RN à cette
manifestation oui vous avez marché à
côté
d'eux qui terrible
vous terrible c'est que ce pressentiment
qui qui est apparu ici il est très clair
la fille a trouvé un prétexte pour ne
pas manifester contre l'antisémitisme
c'est faux monsieur c'est c'est terrible
mais c'est ce qui ressort de vos paroles
je va dire plus samedi je vais être à
Avignon à défiler sur la marche contre
l'antisémitisme contre l'islamophobie
évident et après j'ai demandé à des amis
sur place de bien pouvoir prendre
contact avec le Rabin d'Avignon pour que
je puisse lui apporter mon soutien parce
qu'il a été victime d'acte antisémite à
la sortie de de la synagogue sur la
place pi cette semaine dont personne n'a
parlé voilà où serai monsur s'il vous
plaî ce procès vous n fait
pas sur le climat sur le climat s'il
vous plaît sur le climat j'ai lu une
tribune de de Maurice Levy dans le monde
aujourd'hui qui dit jamais la communauté
juive depuis la Choa ne s'est senti
aussi isolée l'Europe entière n'est pas
épargnée hein par cette vague de
d'antisémitisme en Allemagne on a même
vu des dans les cortèges de
manifestation de soutien à la Palestine
des des des drapeaux de daesh mais pour
l'instant euh il y a pas d'attaque
physique voire pire de mort et a eu par
le passé est-ce que vous redoutez cette
étape là est-ce qu'elle est possible
alors oui l'Europe est pas épargnée vous
le rappelez 1800 actes antisémites en
Allemagne la une du spigle viraben HST
les Allemands ont peur en France la peur
elle est là les associations
antiracistes comme la nôtre je tiens à
vous dire notre service juridique en un
mois doit traiter un surcroix d'appel
multiplié par 300 % avec des signales
acte alors c'est vrai que je suis un
petit peu agacée
par la récupération peut-être
politicienne de ce grand événement qui
doit avoir vous voulez dire par
récupération le fait que la l'initiative
émane des deux têtes du Parlement non
certainement pas ça la
récupération pour dire je viens je ne
viens pas à ce rassemblement je crois
que les Français juifs depuis 15 20 ans
sont incroyablement seuls dans leur
combat et ce rassemblement il est
nécessaire il est nécessaire en surplomb
et au-delà des querelles politiciennes
du double discours de propos qui
viseraient à invectiver les camps
politiques que ce soit de l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite c'est un
moment important pour l'ensemble de la
République et des Français au-delà des
Français juifs qui ont vraiment besoin
d'être accompagnés dans ce grand
rassemblement je tiens à préciser que le
rassemblement du 9 octobre si Mo ma
mémoire est bonne qui avait été fait à
l'initiative de du CRIF a rassemblé
quelques milliers de personnes mais
c'est pas suffisant Carpentra les
profanations de tombe on était sur des
TBS mais c'était important évidemment en
1990 200000 personnes en France qui qui
sortent crier leur refus de
l'antisémitisme et là je crois que nous
on a une sonette on lance la sonnette
d'alarme effectivement au quotidien on a
des signalements 1040 actes c'est du
jamais vu dans l'histoire des 20
dernières années de la délinquence et de
la criminalité antisémite alors vous
l'avez rappelé en 20 ans euh a 13 à 14
français j'ai pas le chiffre précis
Français juifs qui ont été assassinés
dans notre pays c'est pas rien je
voudrais vous faire écouter Emmanuel
Macron qui sans nommer vos deux partis
respectifs le rassemblement national la
France insoumise a mis en garde à la
fois l'extrême droite contre un
amalgamme entre le rejet des musulmans
et le soutien au aux Juifs mais aussi
les insoumis leurs ambiguités sur
l'Hôtel du communautarisme écoutez la
République ne transigera pas sans
prendre un juif c'est toujours chercher
à atteindre la République le Chef de
l'État et veillons à toutes les
confusions dans une époque où les uns
préfèrent rester ambigu sur la question
de
l'antisémitisme par souci de flatter de
nouveaux communautarisme et les autres
prétendent soutenir nos compatriotes de
confessions juives en confondant le
rejet des musulmans et le soutien des
Juifs en refusant cela même de condamner
clairement leur position
passée et tous les mots définitifs
d'hier Nathalie sainric comment vous
analysez les propos du chef de l'État
alors vous vous étiez agacé moi je suis
Narai sans vouloir être caricaturale je
suis Narai parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui ne devrai pas être
dans le débat politique non pas que je
considère que c'est pas du niveau mais
que il y a une peur de la communauté
juive et des autres normalement les
autres aussi devaient se sentir
totalement concernés et après on reprend
des attitudes politiques Jordan
bardellaa bien évidemment quand on lui
demande si Jean-Marie Le Pen est
antisémite va pas dire oui il était
antisémite même s'il le pense on sait
tous du moins ceux qui sont assez âgés
qu'il avait des positions antisémites
qu'il le pensait qu'il a été condamné et
qu'effectivement c'est une époque qui
était comme ça le futur candidat je ne
sais quoi Bardella veut pas dire ça à
cause de Marine Le Pen Olivier verrand
ce matin pour essayer de rééquilibrer
les chos laisse entendre en gros que
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
c'est la même chose c'est on commence
une démarche unitaire attendez et le
chef de l'État aussi il y a une démarche
d'union nationale c'estd on va montrer
qu'on est contre l'antisémitisme on va
essayer d'être nombreux pour rassurer
pour dire on est avec vous et on
commence par séparer tout le monde en
disant ok il va falloir donner un tampon
à chacun vous vous vous vous pouvez vous
pouvez pas mais c'est vrai également que
la France insoumise par ses prises de
position celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
Daniel auonau de manuel monp a été
extrêmement douteuse sur le sujet tout à
l'heure vous dites le conflit
israëlo-palestinien recommence c'est pas
le conflit israëlo-palestinien qui il y
a une attaque du Hamas alors maintenant
une ripose d'Israël mais c'est pas la
aè prise du conflit Israël aupalestinien
le mot on va parevenir sur le débat sur
terrorisme ou pas qui a été refusé qui
n'a pas été nommé si vous voulez on peut
comprendre aussi que par ENF on peut
comprendre on peut expliquer que par une
certaine forme de clientélisme ou pour
avoir le vote B lieu ou pour ne pas
déplaire à certains on choisitê comme ça
mais quand Monsieur Mélenchon parle de
la macronie à la Bronne pivée qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire la macronie à la Brown
pivé c'est désigner quelqu'un du doigt
comme ça en considérant parce que là dit
soutien inconditionnel elle s'en est
expliqué après elle sait elle est
revenue un peu en arrière un soutien
inconditionnel à l'existence d'Israël
non pas à netaniaou alors on y est
chacun vous avez tous si j'ose dire
quelque chose de non clair alors mais
attendezjà c'est intéressant il y a
plusieurs choses vous allez répondre
Antoine Armand mais sur le tweet on y va
on va on va pas vous montrer le sujet
finalement parce que vous avez beaucoup
de choses à dire on avait un sujet pour
vous remontrer ce tweet et ses réactions
mais on l'a tous bien en tête les amis
du soutien inconditionnel au massacre
ont leur rendez-vous c'est ce que dit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à propos de cette
marche contre l'antisémitisme ce
dimanche massacre parlant d'israë
éidemment parlant de laaripost contre le
ramas à Gaza est-ce que vous vous n'avez
pas le sentiment de semer une confusion
générale à travers votre les propos de
votre chef alors je suis très étonné des
propos de Madame saint-ric parce que
précisément on est un peu de la même
génération qui avons cette mémoire des
combats conditionnel contre
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays donc à
un moment donné oui il faut il faut se
faire non pas une autocritique mais
quand même il faut se remettre en
question donc s'il faut que les députés
insoumis moi ou un autre viennent sur
tous les plateaux de télé pour dire le
plus fort possible répéter encore et
encore et encore qu'il n'y a aucun
député de la France insoumise et aucun
militant de la France insoumise qui soit
antisémite et ben on le fera on le fera
autant qu' sera questionz raison de dire
par rapport
parce que nos enfants ne n' pas cette
mémoire de l'histoire et nous avons la
responsabilité j'ai cette responsabilité
de redire que l'histoire de la gauche et
en particulier
C contre l'antisémitisme et racis cette
marche les bombardements de sur Gaza
aller dimanche à cette marche est-ce que
c'est soutenir la roste israélienne g
oui ou non c'est une question très Simp
CZ est-ce que vous croyez sincèrement
que l'on peut
ôter le contexte politique dans lequel
nous sommes la réponse est évidemment
non est vous PZ est- vous
pensez attendez excusez-moi c'est une
autre question qu'on m'a posé je vous
invite à pas dénaturer la question pour
pas dénaturer ma réponse d'accord ma
présence mon absence de présence à Paris
est liée à ce que je dis à la présence
du rassemblement national et de
reconquête j'espère que c'est clair et
qu'il y a pas de sujet là-dessus vous
avez le droit de pas être en accord avec
ce positionnement mais je pense que le
positionement é clair en revanche sur la
deuxème question que vous avez posé la
marche de dimanche pour Jean-Luc mélchon
quand on lit son on comprend que pour
lui ça équiv
sirux qui pensent que la marche de
dimanche est déconnecté de ce qui se
passe en Israël en Palestine non
seulement c'est cynique et c'est un
mensonge donc oui j'aurais participé à
cette marche si il y aurait eu le point
d'équilibre sur l'antisémitisme
évidemment contre l'islamophobie
évidemment parce qu'elle existe et aussi
sur le CESS le feu parce que nous
voulons la paix nous n voulons que il
n'y ait aucun enfant qui Meur ni d'un
côté ni d'un autre tout simplement donc
si ces trois conditions avaient été
réunies et ben je pense qu'il y aurait
pas eu d'ambiguité ni dans un sens dans
l'autre quel naufrage évidemment que
c'est pas déconnecté c'est par vous êtes
vraiment trèss prop mais non mais vous
rendez compte de ce que vous dites mais
vous rendez compteç adress à vous vous
rendez compte ce que vous venez
dire a une conexion évidemment qu'il y a
une connexion vous savez laquelle c'est
parce que c'est parce qu'il y a des gens
comme vous qui amalgam les Juifs de
France avec le conflit israélopestinen
qu'il a des actes antisémites en France
c'est pour ça qui nous a dit qu'on par
éc les questionent
r sousentendez cette petite musique qui
est dans la presse depuis unes moment
qu'on fait ça par clientélisme et ce
mais madame c'est vous qui essentialise
la B moi j'ai grandi en Bonlieu vous ne
pouvez pas dire ça des Bane ce n'est pas
une réalité quand la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale reçoit et je lui
apporte à nouveau mon soutien des
menaces de Mor des menac mite et que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon écrit la macronie à
la Bron Pivet qu'est-ce que c'est si ce
n'est de l'incitation à la violence
c'est c'est ce que vous comprenez moi je
vous pose la question je laisse
comprendre ça monsieur je r quand votre
portepoleoutzexpression ou vous l'z
employ cette expression ou pas vousmême
vous l'riez employé la macronie à la
bonne PIV est-ce que vous l'aurez
employé vous-même cette expression moi
je vous emploie les mots que que j'ai
sur votre plateau j'étais très clair je
seraiis à
avignonch sur la manifestation et
j'apporterai mon soutien au Rabin d'AV
entre les liges très bien BR moi je pens
qu'il faut être simple dans dans dans le
momentquel nous sommes Galina elle bas
c'est évidemment extrêmement
passionnelle et étendu Nathalie Saric a
dit des choses sur la France instum mais
également sur le le gouvernement sitôt
annoncé aussitôt
divisé alors moi je voudrais réagir un
petit peu à ce qu' vient de se dire
parce qu'effectivement j'ai j'ai le
point de vue de la de l'associative de
la praticienne je su aussi avocate sur
ces sur ces sujets d'importation des
Haes je crois qu'il faut vraiment sortir
de la logique des postures ça il suffit
pas de dire je ne suis pas antisémite je
lutte contre l'antisémitisme il faut
avoir un sens aigu de la responsabilité
et quand on est en politique aux
manettes au pouvoir je parle pas de vous
en particulier je parle quand on est au
manette et en responsabilité de son
compte Twitter peu importe la la couleur
politique les mots ont un sens les mots
ont ont des conséquen et quand on tweet
que une soutien une manifest ation sous
prétexte d'antisémitisme encourage les
massacres en Israël et en Palestine
juridiquement on est quasiment dans la
provocation à la discrimination à la
haine antisémite on est dedans même et
on porte une responsabilité sur les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur les
concitoyens de possiblement passer à
l'acte parce qu'on considère que les
Français juifs peuvent être responsables
de la politique en Palestine et à Gaza
alors ça c'est une chose je crois que on
je crois que parfois quand on fait de la
politique on ne se rend pas compte dans
la vie des gens quotidiennement les
répercussions des mots que l'on emploie
et puis cette logique de posture moi je
je le répète elle m'agace elle m'indigne
elle me elle m'inquiète parce que parce
que il faut avoir la responsabilité des
mots qu'on emploie alors c'est aussi une
chose de dire que son parti politique
n'est pas antisémite qu'on renit qu'on
ne et pas faire le ménage dans son
histoire moi je suis aussi extrêmement
choquée d'entendre des responsables du
rassemblement national venir dire que
leur parti
n'a pas de de leader antisémite que
Jean-Marie Le Pen a peut-être été
condamné par la justice mais qu' n'est
pas antisémite Jean-Marie Le Pen il a
aussi une responsabilité collective dans
la société française sur les clichés les
pensciifs antisémites j'ai moi j'ai très
bien en tête le Durafour crématoire
j'étais jeune mais je l'ai en tête euh
les propos sur le point de détail de
l'histoire des chambres à gaz
aujourd'hui on est en train de vivre des
choses très graves en France avec des
résurgences d'apologie de crime contre
l'humanité parce que la vidéo virale de
la des jeunes qui ont été dans le métro
qui ont chanté l'apologie de Hitler et
de ses crimes c'est justement
précisément l'apologie de crime contre
l'humanité alors tout ça c'est un
continuum et si on nettoie pas son
histoire beaucoup d'élus vous demandent
d'être discret dans cette manifestation
de ne pas au fond être en première ligne
le premier rang ou juste derrière les
les deux présidents des des deux
chambres ça vous vous pourriez
l'accepter défiler mais chacun de son
côté alors c'est si j'ai j'ai un petit
peu de temps pour répondre un petit peu
aussi à ce qui a été dit ou ouais alors
pour revenir sur ce que vous venez de
dire les propos de Jean-Marie Le Pen en
question moi je les ai toujours condamné
bon à l'époque j'étais beaucoup trop
jeune pour faire de la politique mais je
les ai toujours condamné j'ai rejoint le
RN récemment après avoir fait un examen
de conscience et m'assurer justement
qu'aujourd'hui le RN n'était plus ce
qu'il était et depuis 2015 quand vous
dites qu'il faut faire le ménage dans le
parti depuis 2015 le ménage est fait je
peux comprendre qu'il y a des
conséquences quand qu même je peux le
comprendre mais le ménage est fait
aujourd'hui le RN n'est pas un parti
antisémite encore une fois nous irons
marcher contre l'antisémitisme je
déplore d'ailleurs toutes ces manœuvres
qui sont mises en place pour faire de la
politique pour diviser pour alu Emmanuel
Macron qui vous accuse en fait sous
couvert de soutien aux Juifs de masquer
au fond votre haine des musulmans c'est
ce que dit le président mais pas du tout
pas du tout on a aucune haine envers les
musulmans la seule haine qu'on a on a la
haine envers le Hamas ça vous fait peut
par non mais attendez vous dire
qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train de dire
là terrorist F de vous autorise vous
autorise
pas c'est pas une litanie vous ne dites
pas que nous sommes des soutiens du
terrorisme du Hamas
ça juste terminer ma phras par j'ai pas
pu aller au bout juste si je peux aller
au bout on nous reproche des mots d'hier
ce serait bien de faire le ménage sur
les mot d' aujourd'hui quand on parle
d'une organisation terroriste comme d'un
groupe de résistant effectivement on
apporte un soutien indirect à un une
organisation terroriste et vous Ortez
sur le territoire national un conflit
qui malheureusement qui malheureusement
fait du mal aux Juifs en France je
déplore qu'on n pas une unité nationale
au moins pour cette manifestation qui
devrait montrer un exemple d'unité de la
nation face à l'antisémitisme je le
déplore on sera présente dans la
manifestation maintenant s'ils veulent
pas être à côté de nous j'ai envie de
dire quelques secondes pour conclure
pour dépasser pour
dépasser just sur cette affaire
d'antisémitisme Jean-Marie Le Pen il
commence à avoir bon do au RN parce que
figurez-vous que Marine Le Pen elle est
entrée au rassemblement national au
Front national à l'époque en 1986 1986
c'est la date où Jean-Marie Le Pen a été
condamné pour ses propos antisémites sur
Elkabach la carrière politique de Marine
Le Pen c'est une carrière dans un parti
antisémite il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont le parti du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
aujourd'hui n'est pas capable de le
reconnaître mais vous voulez vraiment
qu'on parle de l'istoire parouvrir le
débat vous êtes bien exprimé on va on va
s'arrê par socialiste par merci d'être
débattre en direct on voit que le sujet
est électrique il y a une manifestation
ce dimanche et les Français qui nous
regardent feront leur choix d'y aller ou
pas merci à vous espérons qu'il viennent
très nombreux c'est dit merci à vous
vous restez avec moi Nathalie saintrig
dans une dizaines de minutes les partis
pris de nos affranchis ce soir on va
parler avec Isabelle lasser des accords
d'abrah d'Abraham plus que compromis par
cette guerre entre Israël et le ramas
Richard verli va pousser un coup de
gueule contre l'Europe qui qui se
détourne de l'Ukraine et puis dans
Bourbon Express Elsa quel est le
programme je vous parle des QAG des
questions au gouvernement c'est le mardi
mais bientôt ce sera le mardi et le
mercredi sur LCP bien sûr merci els mond
d'ingava tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va plonger dans votre livre
Nathalie sac qui nous emmène dans 1960
le 18 juin exactement 15-0 de la France
combattante choisie à la Libération et
adoubé par le général de Gaulle font
leur entrer dans la crypte du Mont
Valérien c'est un grand moment
historique sauf que sauf que parmi tous
ces cercueils se cachent un traître
regardez c'est dans l'invitation de
Stéphanie Despierre et on en parle tout
les de juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite Nathalie sakric
c'est parce qu'après des décennies de
journalisme politique aujourd'hui vous
nous tenez en haleine avec un roman
policier basé sur une histoire vraie qui
a failli ébranler le régime Gauliste
éditorialiste à France 2 vous avez
longtemps diriger le service politique
de la chaîne publique après le récit du
dernier amour de Clémenceau vous publiez
un second livre l'ombre d'un traître une
ombre qui plane sur le Mont Valérien sur
l'inauguration de ce mémorial de la
France combattante voulu par le général
de Gaulle c'est une drôle d'hoire où le
pouvoir Gauliste a frôlé le scandale à
la Libération le général de Gaulle veut
honorer 15 français qui se sont battus
soit dans le débarquement soit dans la
Résistance il demande à ce qu'on
choisisse 15 personnes sur des listes
tiré au sort pour les honorer au
montvalérien et dans le tirage au sort
et a une erreur on se rend pas compte
tout de suite et ça seraire il un
monsieur qui est plus que douteux et ça
durera pendant 15 ans jusqu'à ce qu'on
réussisse à le faire sortir le passé
trouble de cet homme Robert B est connu
du ministère des Anciens Combattants dès
la fin des années 40 mais ça dépouille
n'est exfiltré de la crypte du
montvérien qu'en 1960 inextrémiste avant
l'inauguration en grande pompe il ne
faut pas que ça se sache au risque de
briser ce moment de communion nationale
dans ce polar les fait historiques sont
vrais mais tout le reste est fiction
pour raconter ce secret d'état Nathalie
Saric vous inventé désirer un apprenti
journaliste qui croit tenir là son
premier scoop il se lance dans une
enquête à force d'intimidation et
d'oppression il renonce à publier ses
révélations dans ce livre vous la
difficulté au sortir de la guerre de
faire le tri entre les vrais et les faux
résistants vous dénoncez aussi les
petits arrangement du politique avec la
vérité historique à une plongée purement
journalistique dans les archives vous
préférez désormais le
romanesque alors Nathalie sa cette
nouvelle vie d'écrivain est-ce parce que
les politiques désormais vous
ennuient réponse c'est pas gentil de me
poser la question comme ça disons que
jeouve parfois une forme de lassitude
mais peut-être parce que c'est parce que
ça fait trop longtemps que je le fais ou
peut-être parce que en ayant commencé
sous à la fin de mi-terran en ayant vu
Chirac gcar pas quoi même le niveau a
bien baissé bah non je vais pas dire ça
mais c'est pas que le niveau c'est que
tout a changé c'est-à-dire qu'il y avit
pas Twitter il y a pas les chînes d'info
on pouvait s'exprimer plus librement les
gens acceptaient de débattre aujourd'hui
quand vous voulez monter une émission
politique à un débat c'est la croix et
la bannière chacun considère que son
standing ne lu Perm pas de débattre avec
un voilà que vous apporte les crrit
que vous apporte personnellement le le
roman que vous ne trouvez pas dans dans
le journalisme vous auriez pu faire un
essai
documentaire politique on a l'impression
que vous vivez un peu votre meilleure
vie comme disent les jeunes aujourd'hui
bah disons que c'est une deuxième enfin
ou une autre ou une parallèle je trouve
bah d'abord j'aime bien ça c'est quelque
chose que j'avais jamais fait donc je
trouve ça pour pas trop s'encroûter je
trouve ça toujours pas mal d'essayer de
s'essayer à quelque chose ça me fait
faire de l'histoire et je trouve que
c'est ça donne un peu de profondeur de
chiant par rapport à ce qu'on peut faire
quand on est journaliste et euh j'aime
bien les dénicher des des choses ou les
dénicher des histoires alors là vous
avez vraiment
dénichés l'impensable l'incroyable que
personne ne connaissait jusqu'à présent
comment vous êtes tombé sur cette
histoire parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
m'a dit innocemment une historienne qui
m'a dit on rentre au au mon Valérien oui
je lui demandé comment comme on était
choisi elle me l'a dit et elle m'a dit
on en sort donc j'ai trouvé que c'était
assez l'idée de sortir mon Valérien vous
y avez cru tout de suite ou pas ah c'est
une femme très sérieuse c'est une
référence en matière de guerre Frédéric
n duf donc pas une seconde j'ai cru
qu'elle m'avait fait une blague toute
façon ça va pas être une blague de très
bon goût donc ça murit un peu puis je
suis allé la voir ENF je je l'ai appelé
en disant mais attendez votre truc là
c'est c'est vous êtes moqué de moi ou et
me dit non non pas du tout mais cherchez
et en fait c'est pas que j'étais un
génie de la découverte ni un génie de de
la comment dire
de c'est qu'en fait je pense que où ça
intéresse personne où ça a été caché
longtemps et maintenant c'est sorti mais
finalement j'ai retrouvé de façon moins
compliquée que je n'aurais pu l'imaginer
et vous retrouvez assez vite Robert B
vous appelez des historiens vous appelez
même des fonctionnaires de la DGSE vous
allez aux archives et vous tomber
finalement sur les PV de celui que vous
avez choisi de de garder anonyme Robert
B pour sa famille sil en a enfin il a
pas d'enfant je sais puisque j'ai
retrouvé même ses actes de divorce j'ai
retrouvé beaucoup d'éléments de sa vie
mais surtout comme c'est un nom
assez courant dans le sud pour éviter
que de jeter lepre sur certaines
personnes parce qu'on n'est pas
responsable ni de ses parents ni de ses
grands-parents ouais vous retrouvez même
sa photo le 10 et 11 novembre 1945 le
général de Gaulle veut absolument
marquer les esprits on ser on sort de la
guerre et la France s'arrête pour
honorer la mémoire des résistants à
l'Arc de Triomphe puis au suite aux
Invalides expliquez-nous comment ces 15
résistants sont choisis alors général de
Gaulle veut avoir sa cérémonie veut
avoir son jour il considère que ce qui
ce qui couronne si j'ose dire rappelle
la mémoire de la guerre de 14 Tom du
soldat inconnu ce qu'on va fêé bientôt
le 11 novembre et quelque chose qui est
spécifique à la guerre de 14 et lui veut
son monument il le veut d'autant plus
que les communistes revendiquent à la
Libération le parti des 75000 fusillers
en laissant entendre que ils leur
contribution à la résistance est énorme
elle a été très grande mais en omettant
aussi qu'au début il y a eu le PCT
germano-soviétique et que c'est un tout
petit peu plus compliqué bref il y a un
concs cours de mémoire où il y a une une
lutte mémorielle entre les deux et de
Gaulle veut avoir son monument pour son
18 juin c'est d'ailleurs le 18 juin 60
vous l'avez dit et il demande à Henri
freené qui sont ministre des Anciens
Combattants de faire un tirage au sort
sur des listes de résistants qui
représentent tout alors c'est-à-dire des
des militaires qui ont qui sont morts
lors du débarquement de Provence
d'autres qui sont morts pendant la
période 39 40 des femmes des hommes des
résistants des gens qui ont été déportés
bref d'avoir quelque chose qui doit
représenter la France combattante il
fait des discours il en parle et parmi
les 15 qu'il va honorer ce jour-là au
sortir de la guerre il y a quoi comment
on peut l'appeler un traître vraiment un
imposteur oui enfin il est traître il
l'a été c'est pour ça qu'il ne mérite
pas d'y être il n'est pas impostur
puisque il est mort et on l'a choisi lui
donc simplement je ne pense pas que ce
soit un complot c'est une une énormité
quoi une bavure une erreur qui n'est pas
dramatique je veux dire il y a des
choses qui sont dramatiques c'est
d'avoir dénoncé des g lui un peu mais le
le c'est le fait qu'il était mis dans un
endroit mais ça quelque chose d' à la
fois grave d'un point de vue symbolique
et un peu ridicule d'un point de vue de
la narration parce que qu'on se rende
compte alors il y a des lettres on
apprend en 46 47 bon et puis tout d'un
coup degul revient en 58 il veut faire
son 18 juin le monument a été construit
on transfère les cercueils et là ils se
disent on a oublié de l'enlever c'est ça
qui est dingue le 15 ans plus tard pour
bien comprendre de GA va quand même
aller jusqu'à s'incliner le jour de
l'inauguration du mot Valérien devant un
cercueil vide il passe enfin j'étais pas
dedans donc je ne peux pas mais
simplement il est au courant et enfin il
passe vite quoi parce que c'est quand
même alors il faut mieux qu' se qu'
passe devant un cercueil vide que plutôt
de s'incliner devant quelqu'un qui a
dénoncé quelques personnes de son réseau
parce que je une fois encore je ne porte
pas de jugement sur des gens qui
auraient pu sous la torture pour des
raisons que chacun peut comprendre euh
balancé mais lui c'est plutôt pour avoir
une vie plus commode même si sa vie a
fini dramatiquement donc une fois encore
je suis pas là pour donner des bons
points oui oui bien sûr d'ailleurs vous
retrouvez l'ex-femme de
reberbé qui ça a été assez violent mais
qui savait qui savait oui je pense mais
simplement il a rien à faire là et et la
mémoire c'est important puisque il y a
encore des gens qui vont m' valer rien
aujourd'hui il y a encore des gens qui
s'inclinent sur la tombe de Berty
albrche qui c'est s'est suicidé plutôt
que de parler
euh voilà sur la tombe du de la petite
fille du grand Rabin qui s'est engagé
dans la Résistance je parle de parce
qu'il y a deux femmes donc je parle des
femmes et tous ces gens qui ont sacrifié
leur vie qui le plus jeune a 20 ans
ouais c'est en coulisse d'ailleurs c'est
c'est la panique car l'affaire aurait pu
être révélée par la presse ça aurait été
un scandale immédiat ce qui fait qu'en
fait c'est qu'après la cérémonie que
finalement le 18 juin 3 mois plus tard
c'est ça que ce cercueil vide sera à
nouveau rempli par un véritable
résistance c'est compliqué il faut en
panique trouver quelqu'un parce qu'on
peut pas laisser un cercueil vide euh il
faut que ce quelqu'un ait des critères
enfin réponde aux critères de cette
fois-ci parce qu'on va pas accumuler les
faux résistant et il faut toujours dans
la politique de de Gaul que ce soit
quelqu'un qui incarne quelque chose
puisque ces combattants doivent chacun
incarner une partie de la une partie de
la France la France coloniale il y a des
Marocains il y a des tirailleurs
sénégalais il y a peu de gradé plutôt
des gens qui sont sortis du rang voilà
donc tout ça c'est un équilibre
politique puis qu'il y a un enjeu de
mémoire très important et on cherche
quelqu'un désespérément et on le trouve
400000 résistants pour 41 millions
d'habitants sans compter que beaucoup
ont basculé dans la Résistance juste à
la fin c'est aussi pour ça que vous
racontez cette histoirelà euh pour dire
que voilà il y a des degrés dans la
Résistance euh tous ne l'ont pas été
certains l'ont fait croire euh on peut
pas mettre tout le monde sur un pied
voilà alors j'ai eu peur avec enfin j'ai
eu peur initialement qu'en écrivant ça
ça débouche sur une forme de relativisme
qui est vous voyez à la Libération on
l'a mis là il a été résistant au début
après il a été collabo mais vous savez
le le fameux oh c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué cette période ça ça c'est
quelque chose qui qui alors c'est
souvent compliqué c'est toujours
intéressant de voir pourquoi c'est
compliqué reste quand même la bouillie
de mémoire la bouillie mémorielle qui
est de dire bon en gros tout ça c'est
tout quand on était au STO ouis c'est
pas la même chose que quand on a rés la
même chose quand on a pris le Maqui on
peut comprendre qu'on soit allé au STO
parce que les Allemands disaient on va
tuer votre père votre mère vos enfants
votre compagne on peut comprendre mais
on ne peut pas dire que d'un point de
vue du courage ou d'un point de vue de
l'attitude c'est la même chose il y a
des gens qui ont été résistants et
d'ailleurs ceux qui le clament le plus
n'est pas ceux qui l'ont exercé le
plutôt il y a des degrés de résistance
des gens qui ont caché simplement je
dirais simplement qui ont mis leur vie
en péril en cachant des juifs ou en
s'engageant il y a des gens qui ont
transmis du courrier il y a tout ça jeun
pas de brevet je veux simplement enfin
je voudrais qu'aujourd'hui le temps
passant on ait quelques idées et que
peut-être on se disent que la version du
général de Gaulle qui é une version
nécessaire probablement quand on arrive
au pouvoir on peut pas se permettre de
dire vous on va vous dégager on va
épurer c'est faire croire aux Français
qu'ils avaient tous été formidables et
merveilleusement résistant alors qu'on
sait que ceux qui avaient suivi Pétin
ont également accueill de après c'est
passionnant on suit désiré l'apprenti
journaliste qui gr gr à son enquête à
François et à sa petite copine Colette
qui va le tuyoter parce qu'elle
travaille au ministre ministère des des
armées va voilà découvrir des choses
être très intimidé il y a le sac qui qui
vient vraiment parti communiste par mais
le patron du bal h prévé juste pour nous
parler de lui parce que vous l'avez
inventé c'est un ancien compagnon de la
Libération qui à la fois le protecteur
de désirer mais qui ne veut pas que la
vérité soit révélée parce qu'il
considère que c'est pas le moment il le
dit un moment donné les historiens
diront mais il a peur qu'à cette période
les gens qui ont été un peu douteux se
saisissent de ça en disant voyez bien
moi vous m'accusez de mais regardez vous
aussi c'était plus compliqué la
résistance c'était des règlements de
compte et il se dit que pour la une
sorte de raison d'État ilinterdit pas
desésér il lui dit c'est franchement pas
le moment voilà don et tout le monde se
pose peut-être j'espère en regardant ça
enfin en lisant ça l'idée où est la où
est la frontière qu'est-ce que j'aurais
fait c'est la question que tout le monde
s'est toujours poser un jour ou l'autrei
pendant la guerre j'auris fait si
j'étais à ce moment-là et on a pas de
réponse merci beaucoup Nathalie Saric
c'est passionnant l'ombre d'un traître
ça ça se lit comme un bon Pol et en même
temps on apprend énormément parce que
tous les faits historiques sont vrais je
voulais vous donner un petit coup de
chap aussi pour votre petit rôle dans le
clémenenceau sur sur France 2 c'était il
y a 2 jours avec un un pierreardi
magistral c'était l'adaptation en
téléfilm de votre premier roman je vous
aiderai à vivre vous m'aiderez à mourir
sur le dernier amour de Clémenceau vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure des des
affranchis pour leur partie prix on va
les accueillir tout de suite ils vont
vous faire réagir
Nathalie allez c'est parti pour les
chroniques de fin d'émission Richard
Verly du quotidien suisse blique qui va
nous parler d'Europe comme chaque
semaine Isabelle laasserre du Figaro
pour l'Internationale on va revenir sur
le proche orient dans un instant avec
vous mais on commence avec Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est vous qui nous l'a raconz Amandin
Gava bonsoir à vous bonsoir je vais vous
parler ce soir d'un consensus j'insiste
sur ce mot puisque on l'a vu dans
l'émission on est dans un temps troublé
d'affrontement de polémique mais là il y
a quelque chose qui faisait l'unanimité
ici à l'Assemblée il fallait réformer
les QAG les questions au Gouvernement
c'est la présidente de l'Assemblée yel
Bron pivé qui avait lancé cette idée
elle voulait redynamiser ce qui est bien
le rendez-vous ici à l'Assemblée et ça y
est ce matin elle l'a annoncé au
président de groupe on va changer de
formule on passe de ce qui existait
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire une séance
hebdomadaire le mardi pendant 2h on va
passer à deux séances une toujours le
mardi 1h et/art et une le mercredi 45
minutes à 14h entre le Conseil des
ministres et les questions d'actualité
au Sénat de séances hebdomadaires
c'était le système qui existait avant la
réforme de l'ancien président de
l'Assemblée Richard Ferrand en 2019 et
cet après-midi au qu colonne avec Ivan
an avion nous n'avons croisé que des
députés contents on a trouvé un sujet
d'unanimité on change la formule des
question au gouvernement ça a l'air de
convenir à peu près à tout le monde oui
on cherche à être moins indigeste dans
l'exercice c'est vrai que 2h top chrono
de question au gouvernement il y a une
forme de lassitude parfois de répétition
et le faire sur de jours ça permettra
d'étaler les sujets de permettre un
débat de qualité et peut-être aussi une
plus grande écoute de la part de nos
concitoyens oui c'est un rendez-vous qui
avait perdu un peu de sa saveur tout à
fait tout à fait parce que c'est c'est
un moment très très très attendu la
question gouvernement attendu par tous
les députés parce que c'est le seul
moment où on peut poser des questions au
ministre donc le fait de poser cette
question avec un hémicycle vide ça ça
perd de son sens qu'est-ce que ça peut
changer dans la répartition des
questions dans les thèmes abordés dans
je sais pas l'exercice de ces questions
gouvernement au moins on aura des
séances qui seront courtes qui seront
toniques dans lequel on va retrouver un
peu de dramaturgie et puis peut-être
voilà quoi de de la tonicité dans les
échanges entre les parlementaires et le
gouvernement c'est important parce que
c'est quasiment le seul moment où on
peut avoir un contrôle direct en
interrogeant le gouvernement sur son
action bon ils sont tous d'accord pour
une fois la vérité c'est qu'il
supportaiit plus la la précédente
version des des questions au
Gouvernement non bah faut le rappeler la
séance du mardi c'est 28 ou 29 questions
2 minutes par question 2 minutes par
réponse ça dure souvent plus de 2 heur
et à la fin bah on compte une dizaine
une vingtaine une trentaine de députés
sur les banqus alors qu'est-ce que ça va
changer concrètement donc 1h15 le mardi
45 minutes le mercredi solution miracle
alors c'est pas for forcment la solution
miracle évidemment c'est plus court donc
ce sera plus facile d'y assister mais ce
qu'il faudrait c'est que les députés qui
posent les questions bah écoutent
vraiment les réponses et puis que le
gouvernement donne vraiment réponde
vraiment pu que ça les oppositions le
soulignent beaucoup pour elle le
gouvernement joue pas vraiment le jeu
vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement ne répond pas vraiment
c'est j'ai le sentiment que le
gouvernement ne répond pas du tout c'est
très exceptionnel qu'il répondent et
d'ailleurs c'est le sujet de pour moi de
ces questions au gouvernement parce que
c'est le seul moment où on peut
véritablement s'adresser au gouvernement
sur des sujets libres et en fait le
gouvernement souvent prend des chemins
de fuite évite les questions répond à
côté et ça c'est pénible parce que ça
rajoute au sentiment de de frustration
voire de dénis du rôle du Parlement dans
la démocratie alors c'est une
expérimentation une expérimentation
pendant 10 semaines à partir du 21 et du
22 novembre évidemment ce sera suivre
sur LCP merci beaucoup vous regardez
encore les questions au Gouvernement oui
c'est vrai absolument parce que
indépendamment de de ce qui a pu être
dit que le le le côté surfait
c'est-à-dire que c'est un peu un numéro
les gens posent des questions pourquon
les entend de poser des questions et les
gens répondent enfin les gouvernement
répond pour que les entendre répondre en
S fichant et l'un et l'autre souvent je
trouve que c'est on n pas beaucoup de
débat parce que je sais que ça se fait
en commission et qu'il faut pas accuser
l'absentisme au Parlement mais par
moment on a quand même des affrontements
puis quand on aime un peu l'oratoire
parfois on trouve il y a des choses qui
ne sont pas que de la forme et aussi du
fond et une jolie forme comme sous
clémau donc j'aime bien parfois c'est
vrai je m'ore ai parliez de clémenceo
dans l'hémicycle dans dans votre premier
livre on'en on s'en souvient avec talent
Isabelle vous vouliez revenir sur ces
accords d'Abraham au fond quoi morné
après après ce qui se passe en Israël et
et à Gaza bon c'est là c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose mais en tout
cas ils sont menacés alors souvenez-vous
qu'est-ce que c'est les accords
d'Abraham d'abord c'est le seul
diplomatie le seul succès diplomatique
de Donald Trump ce sont des accords qui
ont été passés entre Israël et les
Émirats arabes unis puis avec Bahrain
puis avec le Soudan puis avec le Maroc
des accords de normalisation des
relations diplomatiques avec Israël
sachant que deux autres pays l'Égypte et
puis la Jordanie avait eux-mêmes
quelques années plus tôt enfin plusieurs
années 79 pour l'Égypte et puis en 94
pour la Jordanie fait la paix avec
Israël ils sont très importants ces
accords parce que ils ont un potentiel
de de de stabilisation dans dans dans
toute la région même Benjamin netaniahou
a parlé de de tournant historique alors
l'Arabie Saoudite le grand géant sunite
de la région devait être le prochain
pays à les rejoindre et ce n'est pas un
hasard si le les attaques terroristes du
Hamas ont eu lieu le 7 octobre au moment
même où en fait le rapprochement entre
l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël s'accélérit en fait l'Iran a
voulu faire capoter les accords
d'Abraham et le rapprochement entre
TelAviv et Riyad la suite qu'est-ce qui
peut se passer est-ce que les États
arabes vont se retirer de ces accords
alors pour l'instant non pour l'instant
les accords d'Abraham tiennent bon il y
a eu des en fait des mesures cosmétiques
comme le rappel des des ambassadeurs de
la Jordanie par exemple et de de Bahrain
et une mise entre parenthèse du
rapprochement entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël mais les Émirats arabes unis pour
l'instant tiennent bon veulent
absolument sauver les accords d'Abraham
ils sont engagés avec tous ces pays qui
ont fait la paix avec Israël à essayer
de trouver des solutions diplomatiques
et politiques pour l'après-guerre le
jour d'après et la situation à long
terme ten c'est de plus en plus
difficile parce que les régimes de ces
pays donc qui font vraiment le grand
écart désormais entre leurs partenaires
Israéliens et les opinions arabes qui
sont devenus de plus en plus pro Hamas
il faut voir que par exemple aux Émirats
Arabe Unis le Hamas est considéré comme
un mouvement terroriste et ben depuis le
le le l'offensive israélienne enfin la
réponse militaire israélienne au 7
octobre à Gaza le Hamas est considéré
dans ces dans ce ce pays par les
populations comme un mouvement de
résistance et alors les images du 7
octobre par exemple ont complètement
disparu de de des populations de ces
pays arabes c'est comme si elles avaient
été complètement complètement effacées
alors résultat
euh effectivement la colère gronde
complètement et les les les pays des
accords d'Abraham sont fait dansent sur
un volcan il marche sur des œufs qui
menacent de se briser jour après jour et
en fait tout va dépendre de la durée de
l'offensive militaire à Gaza on suit ça
avec vous grâce à vous si j'ose dire
merci beaucoup euh Isabelle on termine
par votre coup de gueule de la semaine
Richard apparemment vous êtes pas
content parce que une fois de plus et
bien les les Européens la Commission
européenne a décidé le report de
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine mais aussi la Moldavie et
la Géorgie et ça tombe pile au moment
d'une forme de grosse fatigue sur le
front ukrainien alors elle n'a pas
décidé de elle a approuvé le rapport sur
l'élargissement mais par contre la
fatigue elle est bien là et bien oui les
Européens sont fatigués ils sont
fatigués de devoir aider l'Ukraine ils
sont fatigués de devoir livrer des armes
au côté des États-Unis vous savez ce
grand frère qu'on adore détester en
France ils sont déjà fatigués de devoir
négocier la future adhésion avec des
Ukrainiens qui sont àides de démocratie
et dont le courage il faut quand même le
rappeler notre bouclier contre la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine ils sont fatigués en
fait de devoir défendre pendre nos idéos
démocratiques et nos libertés à l'est de
l'Europe alors que le Proche Orient est
au bord de l'explosion alors vous savez
quoi moi je n'en peux plus de cet
argument et de cette soi-disant fatigue
ça ne veut pas dire attention qu'il faut
faire rentrer l'Ukraine demain dans
l'Union européenne là il y a un vrai
sujet et il peut y avoir de vrais
problèmes ce que je veux dire c'est que
la tendance des Européens à détourner le
regard à se regarder le nombril et à
préférer leur confort c'est juste
insupportable alors fatigue de la guerre
mais pourquoi est-ce que c'est parce
qu'on rêve de racheter du gaz pas cher à
Poutine comme vous le voudreit la
Hongrie est-ce que c'est parce qu'on est
sollicité à Gaza soi-disant parce qu'en
fait on ne fait que de l'aide
humanitaire et encore cette fatigue
Myriam elle est redoutable parce qu'elle
dit notre manque de courage comme si
nous européens nous étions des animaux
domestiques tressés de rentrer à la
niche alors que la jungle mondiale elle
est pleine de fauves et ben voilà P sur
le bec de l'Europe pourtant ça ça prend
quand même du temps ça mérite un peu de
réflexion que d'intégrer l'Ukraine dans
l'Union non absolument mais le la
fatigue justement c'est le contraire de
la vigilance don l'Union européenne a
besoin alors ouvrons les yeux si l'Union
européenne n'aide pas l'Ukraine à tenir
et à se réformer alors que va-t-il se
passer quel message allons-nous envoyer
au monde après toutes les promesses
qu'on a faites et vous pensez qu'à
Washington surtout avec éventuellement
Donald Trump les Européens fatigués
seront pris au sérieux dira l'Ukraine
qu'elle n'intégrera pas l'Union
européenne d'un coup de baguette magique
c'est indispensable mais pour que les
Ukrainiens l'acceptent il faut être à
leur côté la fatigue européenne ce n'est
au fond qu'un autre mot pour cacher ce
qui nous menace ce sur quoi mise
Vladimir Poutine et son copain hongrois
Victor Orban ça s'appelle le défétisme
boom ben voilà un parti prix une petite
réaction avec un ce qu' qu'on peut tous
déplurer c'est queun actualité chassant
l'autre on se il y a des grandes
déclarations martiales du genre on les
abandonnera jamais on fera toujours ça
et puis au bout d'un moment il y a autre
chose qui se produit et puis on oublie
et puis ça arrange tout le monde
d'oublie et puis pourra jeis pas
rajouter parce que sur le défétisme et
aussi cette espèce de volonté à tout
prix d'avoir la paix quoi on peut avoir
la paix c'est bien d'avoir la paix mais
n'importe quel prix faut que tout le
monde le fasse enfin je dire faut que ça
soit partagé merci merci beaucoup les
affranchis merci Elsa et Merci à VOUS
Nathalie sa lisit l'ombre d'un traître
aux éditions de l'Observatoire vous vous
instruirez tout en vous amusant parce
que c'est aussi plein d'humour ce ce
polar voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre gracien à
[Musique]
demain
he